[Music]
and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber and thanks for
joining us big name Hollywood actress
and entrepreneur Gwyneth Paltrow spent
another day inside of a Utah courtroom
as attorneys try to convince a jury that
she's at fault for a ski slope accident
it happened seven years ago at Deer
Valley Resort in Park City Utah Paltrow
and Terry Sanderson a retired
optometrist who's now in his 70s we're
traveling down a slope at the same time
and one of them crashed into the other
What's Up For Debate is which one
because each claims the other is at
fault now while Paltrow had minor
injuries from the Collision Sanderson
the plaintiff had multiple broken ribs
and suffered a brain injury in fact he
filed a lawsuit in 2019 and then Paltrow
countersuit he's seeking at least three
hundred thousand dollars in damages on a
negligence claim and in her countersuit
Paltrow is requesting just one dollar in
Damages and for Sanderson to cover her
legal fees now as attorneys for the
plaintiff lay out their case for the age
errors medical experts gave testimony on
what they think happened on that ski run
what I believe happened is that he was
struck from the left side
and that forced him into the ground it's
it's also been the testimony here that
Miss Paltrow was on top of him at some
point so the combined weight of the two
individuals slamming into the ground
caused the fracture and the head injury
and I don't think it would be plausible
that if he were running into her that he
would have broken the ribs on the side
of his chest well to make sense of this
we actually had a chance to speak with
Dr bio Curry Winchell an urgent care
physician about the location of
sanderson's fractures and the impact
that a concussion can have on the body
even days later
you know of course we try to
re-uh reimagine you know a fall and how
those injuries happen but it's important
to know that that fall still could have
had other you know twists and turns that
could have caused a fracture on the
opposite side so it's definitely
plausible just because all of those
intricacies to how an injury happens
isn't always
um straightforward when I see patients
you know in the Urgent Care um you know
I'll hear stories of you know I fell
down but I was able to get back up but
then you know a couple of hours later
sometimes days there are symptoms that
are really representative of a
concussion and so sometimes when you
think of shock and and those initial
kind of injury and you get up and you're
like okay I'm fine that is just kind of
part of sometimes our flight our flight
which is that autonomic where you're
just trying to push through however
concussion symptoms do not always show
up right away and so when we think of
those such as fatigue
um inability to concentrate those kinds
of things don't always present itself
right away and so it's something that
you you really have to memorialize
um just to make sure and kind of track
where you're at or if it is a concussion
all right let's break it down I'm
drawing right now by my co-host defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer and our special
guest former Federal prosecutor Nima
Romani and email I'll start with you
it's good to see you I think this is a
battle of experts right when it comes to
Sanderson sanderson's injuries do you
think that's going to play out a certain
way
I do you know obviously this is a ski
crash case but it's no different from a
car accident essentially what you have
is a dispute here it could be a red
light stop sign but here what we're
talking about is the slopes and who are
the right away Sanderson is saying that
he was downhill and we know that
downhill skiers had the right away and
we know that Gwyneth Paltrow is going to
say no no no no I was down the slope and
you crashed into me she's gonna have
Eric the Deer Valley Ski instructor
testify I think she's going to take the
stand as well and she's going to have
family members so two very different
accounts of what happened it's gonna be
interesting how the jury's gonna sort
through it but having medical experts
say that they can definitively determine
that the she he was hit that's going to
be big now everyone agrees Brian that
there was a collision again the debate
is just who struck who does it even
matter that Sanderson was concussed it
doesn't necessarily matter that he was
concussed but as you kind of alluded
there it's about how he became concussed
so yes does he have the proof damages a
concussion and broken ribs is part of
that but in the opening statements from
Paltrow we saw that he could be found
liable if he's more than 51 percent
liable to these injuries and if it's
just an accident Paltrow may not be
liable people get injured in accidents
all the time if his injuries are just so
great because of this eggshell rule of
him being in this state but he hit
Paltrow Paltrow could still win so
concussion not necessarily the ultimate
decider but how it happened is I know we
cover a lot of criminal trials but as
you can see civil trials can sometimes
be even more complicated and so much to
deal with and we're going to talk more
about it
daily everybody our coverage of the
civil lawsuit against actress Gwyneth
Paltrow in Utah continues Now with an
eyewitness account retired optometrist
Terry Sanderson and Paltrow are suing
each other over a mid-slope pile up that
left Sanderson with some serious
injuries now the two disagree over who
slammed into whom now it's one thing to
look at reports or medical records to
determine the culpability of either
party but it is a whole other thing to
actually be on the slope and here's how
a man
skiing with Terry sanderson's group that
day describes the 2016 Collision
we were skiing down
down the bend that down the run and then
and then I heard this this this BL this
this scream and then I looked over and
then about you know maybe one or two
seconds
and then I heard a scream and then and
then and then I see this this this year
just slam into the back Terry and when
she just slammed him how hard very hard
I mean very hard and so Terry she hits
him right directly in the bag and so
then
then his skis are like even when you see
in your skin like this
because skis his skis actually the tips
go out like this and he falls face down
so he's kind of he's kind of spread
eagle and he goes face down and
gwyneth's on the top of him and they go
down like this and then Gwen hits him
and then bounces off and slides to the
right about five or ten feet
important testimony right there but not
the only drama that we've seen you see
before the judge called the jury in on
Wednesday morning Paltrow's attorney
brought up an issue that his client has
with the proceedings the cameras here's
what he had to say before and after a
short recess
your honor we have a new camera pointed
directly at my client right there on the
right which you understand is from the
AP this is a during the recess I'll have
the court representative Tanya take a
look at how that camera's pointed and
make sure that it's pointed at the left
turn rather than at the council table uh
the camera that I reference was a
violation of the decorum order that's
the second violation in two days
directly still photographer directly on
my client's face already transmitted
nationally
so I'm mad
the Quorum order we spent a lot of time
on
it's the Court's order people are
subject to criminal sanction and uh I
want it to stop I don't want to have to
be the one raising it I want them to
comply
so Brian let's go back to the case in
openings sanderson's attorney described
his fall one way but then their star
witnessed seemed to describe it another
way what's the jury supposed to do with
that I mean he said she said you're
expecting that both sides are going to
be consistent in their own stories and
then we figure out which one's more
plausible but when one side has
different variations of Their Own Story
that I think causes disruption in their
case now during opening statements the
attorney for Sanderson kind of put his
arm on the right side almost almost like
a chicken bone so to speak and talked
about falling on the side and that made
sense I mean I played college soccer I
bruised my ribs I've got four or five
different fractures you fall on your arm
on a hard surface you can fracture your
ribs but here the witness says it's more
spread eagle and and Paltrow falling on
his back makes me think well if you're
spread eagle falling in snow whether
it's packed or not how do you get
injuries on your right side so that's a
good point and Nema eyewitnesses they're
great but obviously they have problems
just like all all of us for example the
eyewitness is colorblind and has a story
that changed over time because he said
he got nervous to mixed things up I mean
how is that credible
well this is an important witness
because we know that culture was going
to rely on the ski instructor right so
that was going to be independent witness
and obviously Paltrow's lawyers have
been pretty successful so far they've
gotten a punitive damages stricken no
evidence of a hit and run got the
recklessness stricken so I thought the
plaintiffs were really behind I like
them bringing an independent witness not
only because the witness is independent
they're saying hey guess what the ski
instructor didn't show up till several
minutes later he didn't even see any of
this and Gwyneth Paltrow sat there for
four minutes she was silent she didn't
say a word so she started strong I think
that's the that's the claim it'll be
curious what the jury ultimately
believes we want to actually move right
now to a different story because we have
an update for you in the case of
Zechariah Anderson the man accused of
killing his ex's New Lover in Kenosha
Wisconsin a jury found him guilty of all
charges on Wednesday Anderson faced
first degree murder among other charges
in the death of Rosalio Gutierrez Jr
roughly three years ago the victim was
the new love interest of Anderson's
former girlfriend and she testified
along with her daughter that Anderson
would constantly spy on and attempt to
stalk the couple now prosecutors believe
that Anderson killed Gutierrez at his
own apartment because he was jealous
investigators found blood in several
areas of the victim's apartment and
believed that a struggle took place but
I should tell you gutierrez's body has
never been found Anderson will be
sentenced in May